guys guess what
we got another Marvel TV spot trailer
tonight before we get started be sure to
join the cosmic wonder revolution and
subscribe to my channel the revolution
has begun a few more new scenes in here
one particularly interesting so let's
have a look he won't stop until he
destroys half the universe everything
you know everything you love
it will all be gone together
we can stop flannels
[Music]
you don't want to train
but we will
[Music]
I must warn that of some of my
conclusions and predictions on the
scenes that are analyzed are accurate
they will contain huge spoilers to
Avengers infinity war the first you've
seen we have isn't that different than
the other scenes in the trailers where
Gamora starts them off by talking about
how dangerous and powerful Thanos is she
starts off by saying he won't stop until
he destroys half the universe everything
you know everything you love it will all
be gone again this isn't too different
than the other trailers that we've
gotten but the curious thing is when she
says everything you know everything you
love it will all be gone it cuts to a
scene of Scarlet Witch and vision seems
like there's a little bit of
foreshadowing going on here we don't
know for sure of visions going to die
but we do know that famous wants the
mind stone and it's located in visions
forehead and we've seen in previous
trailers vision pinned to the ground and
someone from the Black Order trying to
take the mine stone from him
hopefully by putting vision and Wakanda
and surrounding him by the wakandan army
and the Avengers they'll be able to
protect him
the next news team we have is of the
Mighty Thor Thor in the scene it looks
like Thor is where he goes to forge his
new hammer Stormbreaker and he's telling
somebody together we can stop Fanus
there's really only a few options of who
he could be talking to in this scene
he's most likely talking to rocket and
teen group trying to convince them to
help him Forge Stormbreaker to take on
Thanos there is a chance however that
he's talking to eat Rhee the king of the
dwarves and a Dobler and he is known to
be the greatest forger and weapons maker
and he also helped create some of the
most powerful weapons at all the nine
worlds including Thor's original hammer
Mjolnir if you look at the official cast
list on IMDB for Avengers infinity war
you'll find Peter Dinklage's name on
there if you also look you'll notice
that he doesn't have an assigned
character to his name given his physical
stature it makes sense that he would
play one of the dwarves on Madhavi lair
and help Thor forge the mighty hammer
Stormbreaker
this next and last scene is all sorts of
exciting to start off we have Scarlet
Witch protecting vision as we can
clearly see vision is severely hurt and
Scarlet Witch is standing in front of
them to protect him we know from
previous trailers that vision gets
attacked by Corvus glaive who is
to get the mine stone from him it seems
like Scarlet Witch and some other
Avengers came just in time to save
vision from Corvus glaive this next
scene is black widow fighting Corvus
glaive but the really awesome thing
about the scene is Black Widow is
fighting him with Proxima midnight
slants this leaves a question how did
she get Proxima midnight slants we've
seen in previous trailers Proxima
midnight through her lands at Captain
America in which he dodges it with ease
and catches it and then we have this new
scene that shows Black Widow Falcon and
Captain America together in what looks
like the same scene that Proxima
midnight throws her Lance at Captain
Black Widow Falcon and Captain America
are all looking at one person in which
Black Widow says we don't want to kill
you but we will it seems like they're
talking to Proxima midnight and they
might kill her in the scene this would
make the fight scene between Black Widow
and Corvus glaive makes sense because in
the comics Corvus glaive and Proxima
midnight are married obviously there's a
lot of new information that we've got
from this new footage in the trailer let
me know what you guys think of it in the
comments below I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the new footage that we've
seen don't forget to join the revolution
and subscribe like this video and follow
us on Twitter thank you so much for
watching woof woof